okay
so i'm going to talk about um burt and
also some
uh kind of precursor work and then some
follow-up work that's happened
in the last year now we'll not follow up
but uh more more recent advancements um
that's happened
uh since then so
uh first we're gonna talk about history
and background so um
everyone knows and loves ward embeddings
in nlp right they're kind of the basis
for
uh neural networks work for nlp
because neural networks work in a
continuous space
vectors and and matrices and obviously
text is a discrete space and so there
needed to be something to bridge the gap
and uh it turns out that the thing to
bridge the gap
it's actually pretty simple it's just a
lookup table from um
each from a set of discrete vocabulary
to a vector that's learned
discriminatively end to end right so
originally these were just learned like
in in uh the original bengio 2003
neural language on paper these were just
trained discriminatively end to end
and these were actually and so then
people train language models and then
use these pre-trained use the embedding
layer as pre-trained representations
um for for other tasks and but they
wouldn't use the rest of the language
model they would just use the embedding
layer
and then uh word develop and glove and
stuff came along where
then people found a much cheaper much
more scalable way to train
it where you can just use the uh
statistics of a corpus where it's just a
linear model so you don't have to
compute these expensive
feed forward layers that you're going to
throw out anyways and so you can scale
up to like billions of tokens
on a single uh cpu right so
the problem though is that these word
embeddings are
applied in the context free matter right
so so for like a kind of a simple toy
example
the word bank if you say open a bank
account and on a riverbank
it's going to be the same embedding so
people are trying to do stuff like
uh word sense embeddings where it's not
just a single word it's a full word
sense
but this kind of bank example is a
little bit of a toy example right most
almost any word has a different meaning
depending on the context
um it's very so even even like open the
bank account and i went to the bank
those are still
in a semi different senses of the word
bank one of them is a i mean they have
different part of speech text kind of
uh well i guess not really but like
they're kind of they're kind of using
different senses right
and so um yeah so so we really need a
contextual representation right so we
want something
where it's a representation of a word
after
it's been put into the context of the
sentence that we've seen it in right
which would be like at the bottom here
so kind of for history of contextual
representations
the first big paper for this type of
contextual organization was a paper uh
from google
in 2015 called semi-supervised sequence
learning from andrew dye and quackley
um and so in this one uh
it was actually very similar to to
papers that came after it it didn't get
as much attention for various reasons
so but basically they they had some
classification tasks like
uh sentiment classification on movie
reviews and they had a big corpus of
movie reviews
and so then they said what happens if we
just take our existing lstm model
and instead of just using pre-trained
embeddings which everyone has already
been doing since like at least
for the like actually probably since
2003. 2003 people have been using
pretending betting's but
they said let's actually pre-train the
entire model as a language model
and then let's fine-tune it for our
classification test and they got
pretty good results but not like stellar
results and so now we know that the
reason why they didn't get sell results
they didn't train it on enough data and
they because they basically turned on
the same corporates that they were
training on
and they trained the same size model
that they were training on which we now
know needs to be bigger
but that's kind of uh this was this was
already kind of a little bit ahead of
its time um
partially because like you know stuff
wasn't like we didn't have this compute
back then
even though it was only five years ago
um and it would have been you know more
expensive
so uh and then in uh 2017
elmo came out which was uh from the
university of washington
and ai2 and so this one
they did something pretty clever where
they took um
you train a language model on a big
corpus so they traded in a billion word
corpus
and they made a big model a lstm with 4
000 hidden dimensions which is quite
expensive
and they trained a bi-directional model
so they but but
it was uh kind of weekly bi-directional
where they trained a left-to-right model
and then a right left-right model and
then they concatenated the two
and they call these contextual
pre-trained embeddings and so the idea
behind elmo
is that this doesn't actually change
your existing model architecture
you kind of take whatever task specific
model architecture you have
which could be you know for uh question
answering it might be some sort of fancy
model where you do a lstm over the
source and over or over the question and
over the answer then you then you attend
to one another
and in whatever kind of architecture you
have and just wherever you would have
put in glove embeddings before now you
put in elmo embeddings
um and so this got state of the art on
you know
everything at the time crescent
answering semantic parts and synthetic
parsing
because it was and and so if you just
took any existing kind of
state-of-the-art model
you could fit in put in mlm and get
state of the art right uh but but they
weren't
uh but these were kind of the models
were kind of fixed
um and so then after that uh
openai published improving language
understanding with generative
pre-training which is
simply called gpt-1 and so in this they
took a just just like a similar large
corpus
about a billion words and they trained a
very large language model so a 12-layer
language model
which at the time was maybe i don't know
whether it was actually a large language
rather than between at the time
certainly was the largest enterprise
that had been trained on that much data
for a kind of open source model
and when i first read it i actually
thought that it was like too big like
not
not that it was worse but that they were
kind of just showing off by showing how
big of a model they could train
but now we know that actually this this
this depth that they had was actually
kind of the crucial
the crucial element so they did
something that was like fairly simple
right that is train the language model a
very large one and then they just
fine-tuned it
by taking the last token and then
fine-tuning it for a classification task
right so is this positive or negative
and they got
basically state of the art on lots of
different classification tasks
but and so i'm going to i'm going to
actually take a uh
kind of a a side here before i go into
bert um which is about transformer so
that was the other uh
kind of big thing like the the big
precursor uh that allowed
bert and gbt to work well right so um
burton gbt both used to transform which
i'm sure you guys have learned about and
so
i i don't need to go into all the
details about it but
um so it has
you know multi-headed attention feed
forward layers layer norm i won't go
into all the details because
i think you guys already learned about
it but so the the big thing
about why this kind of took over is uh
there's really two advantages versus the
lstm
one is that there's no locality bias and
so
um long distance context has a equal
opportunity to short distance context
which is
important so for like normal language
understanding that
the locality bias of lstms is generally
considered to be a good thing
because local context is more
relevant than long-distance context but
the way that gpt and bert and other
models work
is that they actually concatenate
context
and so if you have a uh like a model
that says does this sentence does
sentence one entail sentence two
the way that it was done historically
meaning like before gbt
was that you would like encode them both
let's say with an lstm
then you would do attention from one to
the other with
a transformer you can just put them into
the same sequence
and give them separate sequence of
betting or add a separator token
and it will learn how to uh and then it
can
things can tend to to its own sentence
locally but it can also attend
all the way to the other sentence uh for
almost for
no it's just as easy for it to tend all
the way to the other sentence
and so when you do this kind of you can
just pack everything to a single
sequence and then
uh everything will be learned rather
than rather than having to do this as
part of the
model architecture which is ends up
being a pretty important uh
thing about simplifying these models and
so the other thing
is um that having a
with transformers with with lstms let's
say
this is a batch and these are the words
in the back so you have two sentences
and four words per sentence
every step has to be computed um one at
a time so you only get a batch size of
two effectively
and so on modern hardware which is tpus
and gpus
the bigger the matrix multiplication the
better it is you want all three
dimensions to be big
so even if you have big hidden layers um
your batch size dimension will still be
small
unless you have a huge batch but then
that's too expensive for long sequences
but with transformers it's the total it
because
it's layer wise attention um the total
number
the batch size is the total number of
words so if you have 500 words and then
32 sentences it's actually 32 times 512
is the total batch size so you get these
huge matrix multiplications
and you can take advantage of modern
hardware
and so that's kind of why the
transformer has taken over because of
these two things
and that's why it was used in gpd and
why it's using burp so
now i'm going to talk about bert so
the problem with the previous model
being elmo and gpt and
um bloods before it is that the language
models only used left context or right
context
or a concatenation of both but really um
but language understanding is
bidirectional right so there's this
clear uh
kind of mismatch between why is why did
everyone train on but on unidirectional
models where you could only see to the
left or only c to the right
when really we care when we know that in
order to understand language you need to
look in both directions right
so there's two reasons so one is that
language models historically had been
used for um
typically as features in other systems
so like the most direct application of
language modeling would be like
predictive text right which is directly
just saying predict the next word
the other but the other applications
that are actually more common are to use
them in a machine translation system or
a speech recognition system
where you have these features like
translation features or
acoustic features and then you add a
language model that says what's the
probability of the sentence
and so for this you want it to be a
well-formed distribution for these
pre-trained models we actually don't
care about this but this was kind of
something that was
uh kind of people had just been like
kind of
i guess fixed on this idea that language
models have to have to have a
distribution a probability description
even though we actually don't care about
that
but the other kind of bigger reason is
that words can see themselves in a
bi-directional encoder
and so what this means is when you build
a
representation incrementally
so you have your input and then you have
your output and it's always offset by
one
so we can we have the the startup
sentence token we predict the first word
then we feed in the second word
we fit in the first word the second word
and so we can encode the sentence once
and predict all the words in the
sentence with the unidirectional model
and so this gives us good sample
efficiency right because if we have a
512 dimension
like a sequence of 500 words we don't
want to have to uh
only predict one word because it's going
to be 500 times
as much compute to get the same amount
of predictions
but if we were to just really do a
bidirectional lcm or transformer
we would have a situation where you
encode your sentence every
everything is bidirectional and so after
the first layer
everything can see itself so so this
word open there's a there's a path back
down to open and so it's trivial to
predict a word
that can that can where it's in the
input also right there's no there's no
actual prediction going on there
so the simple solution which is
basically the whole crux support is that
let's instead of
training a normal language model let's
just predict mask out
k percent of the words so uh the man
went to the
mask to buy a mask of milk and so
and so now you can run a bi-directional
model on that and because the words
aren't in the input you can't cheat
right the downs and so
the downside of this is that you're not
getting as many predictions
per sentence right you're only getting
predicting 15 percent of words instead
of
100 of words but the upside is that
you're you're getting a much more rich
model because you're seeing in both
directions right
so this value of k is a hyper parameter
that we have to
uh just decide on empirically so we use
it turns out that that's actually kind
of an optimal value people have so we
and also people since then have done
um more thorough ablation experiments
and found that
this 15 is good so the reason the reason
for doing a certain percent
over another is that if you were to do
let's say 50 masking you would get way
more predictions
but you would also mask out like all of
your context and so
um you can uh if you mask out all of
your context and you're not getting any
you can't learn contextual models and if
you only do
like let's say you could mask out one
word that would that might be optimal
maybe um but you would have to do way
more data processing so it'd be way more
expensive to train and we know that
these models are basically
just compute bound so if you just have
enough data you can just kind of
train them infinitely and it'll always
do better so it's really just a
trade-off between these two these two
things
um so one other little detail invert
which turned out to be super important
is that because the mass token is never
seen at fine tuning time uh instead of
always replacing a word with the masked
token
as in this case uh we would randomly
sometimes
predict it with a random word and
sometimes keep the same word so like so
17 time would say we went to the store
and went to the running right
and so we wouldn't tell the model which
which case was which uh we would
we would just have it we would just have
to
we would just say what what should this
word be right and didn't know whether
it's right or not so
it could be the same word so because 10
percent of time it's the same word it
could be a random word
and so it has to uh basically be able to
maintain a good representation
of every word because it doesn't know
whether it's really the right word so i
actually look at everyone and figure out
whether this is the right word so we
could potentially even just get away
with not using the math token at all and
just doing like this 50
time and this 50 of the time but the
reason for not doing that is that
uh you know then we'd be corrupting a
lot of our data and we don't want it to
necessarily
corrupt the data because the fact that
this is the wrong word might mess up our
prediction for some other word over here
right
so whereas the mass token at least it
knows that it's not the right word so
it doesn't use that as part of its
context um
so the other the other kind of uh detail
of burt which also now and subsequently
may not be
been that important is that a lot of
these tasks that we're doing we're not
just learning
words we're want to predict the
relationship between sentences so
question answering in particular we have
a query which is a
generally a sentence and then we have a
answer which is a paragraph
or a sentence or document and we want to
um you know say does this answer the
question
so by doing that we um so we want to
have some pre-training task
that actually does a sentence level uh
prediction rather than just a word level
prediction so the way that we did this
which
and we need this to have like an
infinite amount of data right where we
can just generate an infinite amount of
data
so we don't want it to be an annotated
task um
so the way that we did this is we
just did a next sentence predicting test
where we just took
two sentences from the same corpus from
the same document and
and 50 time they're from the same
document 50 time there from a random
document
and then we just said was this the real
next sentence
uh or not and so if you have like the
man went to the store he bought a gun on
the milk that is the next sentence he
said the man went to the store penguins
are flightless
that's not the next sentence so
basically now we're forcing the model
at pre-training time to actually make to
look at the full sentences
and then make some sort of sentence of a
prediction and we hope that this
uh is kind of generalized
is something like question answering
where you have a question and answer as
sentence and sends b
uh so in terms of our input
representation
it looks pretty similar to a normal
transformer but we have these
additional embeddings which are called
segment embeddings
so a normal transformer you would have
your input
and then you would do wordpress
segmentation right where you split up re
apply this unsupervised
splitting of words into um
kind of uh morphological splits but
they're usually often not morphological
so it's unsupervised but you end up with
something that's roughly morphological
right
and so now you have like no no out of
vocabulary tokens
everything is represented at least at
the very least you always split into
characters
uh so we use a 30 000 word vocabulary
and then we have our
token embeddings then we have our normal
position embeddings which is the bottom
and so these are
part of the transformer where because
transformers unlike lstms don't have any
sort of um
locational uh awareness so the only the
way to encode that is that you
encode a actual embedding for every
position so this is called absolute
position embedding there's other kind of
techniques nowadays
and so and then you have the segment
embedding which is
this is a sentence a or sentence b and
so this kind of generalizes in more
general context so you can imagine if
you're saying if you're trying to say
like you're trying to do like web search
you might say
here's my query here's the the title
here's the url here's the
document content um and so you can kind
of just pack these onto a single
sequence and then just give them
different
segment embeddings or type embeddings so
that now you get
uh are able to have a much stronger
um you're able to kind of just represent
everything
in this kind of same single sequence
where you kind of just differentiate but
just a single embedding that's different
and this is all of course learned
and so this is in contrast to kind of
the older style where you would
typically have a different encoder for
every part of it so like you would have
a different code for the query and then
maybe for the title and maybe the url
but this case it's all just a single
sequence so
we trained on about a three billion word
corpus which was
at the time large now it's not actually
even that big of a what people are
training on
uh we used a batch size uh which was
also large
um we trained for about 40 epochs over
the data and we trained these two models
which are still relatively large
um so one of them is a 12 layer 768 and
then the other 24 layer 10 24. so at the
time this was basically like
one of the largest models that had been
trained although now people are training
models that i think are
uh 30 times or more bigger than this um
in the more recent papers so things have
kind of exploded in terms of
compute compute in the last i don't know
three years
but uh yeah so
the fine tuning procedure is uh
it's pretty straightforward right so we
we pre-trained this model for these two
tasks and so now
we have an input sequence which is
multiple sentences with different type
embeddings
we feed them through the uh our
transformer
model and now we have the special
embedding
which i think i didn't mention so this
is the special embedding this is this is
basically it's learned to predict the
the next sentence prediction task
and then this is used also for
classification text
but this it's not just that we're using
the embedding right we are
we're fine-tuning the entire model right
so this so it's really not that this
embedding is intrinsically useful or
that the word embeddings are
are useful it's that the the the weights
inside the entire 12 or 24 layer model
are useful and so by fine-tuning the
entire model you can kind of
pick out the salient parts that are that
are important for some downstream task
and so this is this is the kind of the
the class specific fine-tuning freight
so if we have a single classification
task
uh like let's say sentiment analysis
um where i say is this a positive or
negative review we we
encode our sentence with the burp model
then the only parameters that we add are
this
final output matrix right so maybe if we
have three let's say
positive negative or neutral this might
be a thousand times
three right so it's just three thousand
parameters and 300 million
so 3 000 new parameters and 300 million
old parameters
and we jointly train all 300 million
plus 3000
for this downstream task but because the
vast majority of them are pre-trained
we can kind of adapt to it in only like
a few thousand
labeled examples and similarly for a
sentence fair class
we do um we just continue to do
sentences with different type embeddings
so we have if you want to say does this
sentence entail this other sentence you
say sentence a
uh you put it concatenate sentence b and
then
also predicts from from this token and
fine-tune the entire thing so similarly
very few additional parameters for span
prediction tasks
you just have kind of a start of a start
of span and a span so you're only adding
a few thousand new parameters
and then for tagging tasks like part of
speech tagging
you just um have a
single uh sentence you have you you add
every single token or maybe every token
except for the the word pieces but like
you that's kind of pre-processing you
you predict um
what's the part of speech of this and so
this is really why
uh so like word itself is really a kind
of
i would say an incremental improvement
over what art exists so it kind of took
uh transformers uh elmo
gpt really these three ideas and kind of
made
a pretty simple uh change on top of them
and but the reason why it had such big
impact is not just the numbers that i'll
show in a few slides it's really
this this thing because
um with elmo
there was really no fundamental
difference between it was just
contextual embedding right so you
still had because like a lot of deep
learning historically
has been fun in building new models
right so you have all of these
components
kind of like lego blocks right you have
tension layers feed forward layers layer
normalization
lstms etc and you can just
kind of like figure out say okay for
this new task how do i glue these
together
in a way that's best right and so
um and so with elmo it wasn't really
it didn't really change anything
fundamentally it was just because these
were
you just fed it into your existing model
and you got state-of-the-art for
gpt-1 one it wasn't um
most like these things didn't really
work right because it was a
left-to-right language model
and so you could just kind of take the
last token and then predict a
classification test
but it didn't really make any sense to
predict um like part of speech tags
because
for the first word there's no context so
it makes no sense to predict with no
context
um with bert the reason why it had such
high impact
was because it kind of simplified things
and so that's not i'm not saying that's
necessarily
a good thing because as a researcher or
or a bad thing
i'm so as a researcher kind of
ironically the ultimate goal of research
is often like research yourself out of a
job right like
it's like you know if a if a physicist
i'm not saying bert had
anyone near this impact like a physicist
that came up with like the grand theory
of physics
they would kind of like that would be
like the greatest moment in physics but
also that would kind of
uh eliminate a lot of research right and
so that's kind of like the end goal
of richard just kind of solved the
problem right so so
bert um kind of has
a is a step where now
like all of these different kinds of
problems there's really it kind of
killed like a lot of the need to do um
model architecture design which is kind
of
unfortunate because that's like really
fun um and so
that's kind of the the impact and i'm so
i'm not gonna say whether it's like a
good or a bad impact it's kind of like
the objective impact and that's why it's
had so much impact is because
it has kind of had this effect on
now so many things that used to be like
designing fun
you know models it's just feed it in and
use one of these
four recipes and it kind of just works
for all of these different tasks
so in terms of actual empirical results
so these are at the time the paper was
published of course things have gotten
better since then so these this this
glue task
is a set of um they're all kind of
similar in that they're all sentence
pair or sentence classification test
so like multi-nlai would be something
like
hills and mountains are especially
sanctified in jainism and then
hypothesis is jainism hates nature
that's a contradiction right so in order
for a nlp model to be able to understand
this
or to be able to answer this correctly
and give this the label of contradiction
it needs to know
that uh hills and mountains are
part of nature sanctified is a good
thing and that hating something is a bad
thing and be able to do all of this
reasoning right
so it's pretty complicated reasoning
similarly for cola you have to be able
to say like the
the wagon rumbled down the road versus
the car honked down the road
and so um these things are
uh you know one of them to a native
english speaker
sounds totally fine the other one sounds
weird and so it's similar and
neither of these have very much data
right so you have to be able to
generalize on only
uh like a few thousand examples um
so bert uh bass which is the same size
as open ai
uh it significantly beat open ai which
was the previous state of the art
and then uh the uh
bert large which was bigger of course
got better results which is
only surprising that it got better
results across the board including on
the very very tiny data that's only a
few thousand examples that was kind of
that's kind of the more interesting
result rather than just the fact that
uh it got better results because
historically when you uh there was you
know rules of thumb about if you have
some number of examples how do you
design the model size
that's optimal for that and so if you
don't do pre-training like if you keep
making the model bigger without
pre-training
eventually you'll get worse results
because your model will overfit your
training data
with pre-training you basically only
ever do like one pass of the day anyways
so there seems to be almost no limit to
how big you can make it
and still get good results even with a
tiny amount of fine-tuning data and
that's really like one of the one of the
big takeaways
so i'm not go yeah so
uh squad 2.0 i said so the reason why
these are these are numbers
and these ranks are lower because i took
the screenshot
uh after like this you know
significantly after
uh when a bunch of other people had
submitted systems
but um so this is a question and data
set so it'd be like what action did the
u.s take that started the second oil
shock
so in this case there's no answer right
so it's something you have to be able to
predict is that there's no answer in
this
phase uh so we have to either predict
the answer or say there's no answer
so bert beat the um
burpee the previous state of the art but
at the time that it was submitted by
about six points which is you know
pretty big gain
now this has kind of gone past human
level um
but at the time yeah it was it was large
so i'll kind of do some ablation
experiments
or go through some of the bleaching
insurance so this one there's there's
four things that i'm comparing here so
this is all all
burp based size models so the blue line
is kind of the
the bert based model the red line
is if we take out the next sentence
prediction so in our case even though
people have subsequently said that they
don't think it's important
in our case we actually did measure it
and it turns out it seemed like it was
important
to have this next sentence prediction
task
especially for um
kind of question answering tasks which
is this one but it seems to help a
little bit at least in all four of them
uh to to have it so this kind of doesn't
cause there's some strength in
learning some uh model that learns uh
joint that learns a relationship between
sentences so then
this one is the one that makes an
apples-to-apples comparison between
open ai and open asgpt1
and bert right because i also i made the
model bigger but not not per base so
bird base was the exact same size but it
was training more data
so to make it a fair comparison i
basically retrained my own
implementation of
open ai's gpt one and i
uh which is which is this yellow line
and we can see that on on some of the
tests it's not that far although this is
actually a pretty big gap like this this
drop is
you know like four points which is which
is a lot but on some tests like squad
and mrc it was it was way worse and so
for squad it makes sense because squad
is a labeling it's a span labeling task
and so if you only have left context
then words at the beginning have
basically no context
and so you're asking it to do span
labeling on words with with almost no
context
so it really doesn't make any sense and
so of course it's going to do much worse
so then we also added a to make it fair
we also added an lstm
on top of it which is trained from
scratch and this does help a little bit
on some of the tasks but on other ones
it doesn't help so i can swat it helps
because now you have
bidirectional context but on mrbc
because it's a very small task it's only
got 3000 labeled examples
it doesn't help at all so
if this does show that that kind of the
mass language model and the next
prediction
are both important especially the mass
language model
so the other thing uh one of the other
ablations
is that when we when we apply the
the mass language model we're only
predicting 15
of words in the sentence but when you do
a left-to-right language model you're
predicting every single word
conditioning all the words to the left
so one question might be how much does
this make it take longer to converge
even though eventually we know that it
converges at a much better point
if you have a limited training budget is
it better to do a left-to-right model
and so we see that
when you do this mass-language model the
bi-directionality starts to improve like
at the very very beginning because
you're doing so many more predictions
it's true that uh the left right model
does do better at the very
like for like epoch one but then very
soon after because the bi-directionality
is so important
uh it starts to take over and so it's
basically better from almost the start
to do bi-directionality and then it
takes longer to converge but
but the overall convergence is of course
much higher
um and then finally for for uh
this uh ablations um we can see that
going from a smaller model which was 100
million to 300 million parameters helps
a lot which isn't surprising
but the more surprising thing is that
one of these curves these aren't these
aren't comparable
uh um you shouldn't compare the curves
to each other
the point is to look at the curves as a
function of
uh the number of parameters and
see that this one is um this one only
has three thousand
labeled examples and this one has uh 400
000 labeled examples
so in both cases the curves look very
similar which is surprising because
you know the rule of thumb that you're
going to over fit your data if you only
have a few num a few
labeled examples turns out not to really
be true anymore and there's um
you know and these and these curves keep
going up right so now with subsequent
papers which we'll talk about
like this this this big one was 300
million parameters people have gone up
to 11 billion parameters
and still seen similar behaviors you've
still seen the curves go way up and
gotten so that results which is kind of
crazy because
now we know that um you know basically
there's almost no limit
so another thing i want to talk about
before i talk about uh
stuff that's happened since burt um is
the kind of
is even though bert um
itself was in some ways very simple
which is
you know not a bad thing um it was very
successful immediately
and you know part part of that is the
google brand and like you know got a
cute name and stuff like that but i
think that i i spent
a lot of time with the open source
release in particular looking at other
open source releases
and figuring out what people didn't like
about those um
and so i think this is important like
when you're uh when when you're season
or even even
working industry as a and trying to
release something so um
i kind of just listed the things here
that i thought were uh important for
like why why it was uh successful
compared to
other things um so like i'm not trying
to call them out just to be mean because
but like the open ai gpt-1 release was
really uh was not very good
and then the like you said there were
this because the the open eye gbt2
release was very good
um and so uh yeah because it was very
hard to run
and there was not commented the
tensorflow code was very um like it
worked fine like i replicated
it but like the the tensorflow code was
very non-idiomatic
it used all sorts of weird stuff the
python was weird there was no comments
there was basically no instructions
so like um and then other code bases
also are
uh kind of too big it's like people just
wanna like say like we want to have one
unified code base for our entire
you know language team and so they just
put stuff as part of that and people
don't really like that either
so i was very insistent that we'd do a
minimal release so like this we're just
going to release burt it's not going to
be part of anything there's exactly any
external dependencies um
and it's going to be like very well
commented i think that people and it was
kind of also easy to drop in
just the modeling part and just the
tokenization part and and just the uh
the front end which runs like the
training loop and kind of separate all
these out
because um that way and so i think
because of that um
people kind of started using it much
quicker um and of course like all the
publicity helped
but uh i think that uh you know it could
have easily
been not as successful if if it had been
you know done in a different way so uh
it's just
kind of advice so um
yeah so now i'm going to talk about five
models that have
come out since bert that have all
improved on top of burt in various ways
there's been more than five
but i'm going to highlight these five so
i think that they're interesting
a lot of them didn't come from google
but it's not because this is well
a lot of them involved google i would
say many of them actually were not
they were they were interns at google
from various universities
who were supervised by google
researchers and also use google compute
i mean the reason why a lot of them came
from google is because like frankly like
other than
facebook google and microsoft there's
not really many uh
like people that can the companies that
have the resources to train these
huge state-of-the-art models and so
almost by necessity it's gonna it's
gonna come from one of these um
one of these labs so the first one
was roberta and so this is probably the
one that had like the least uh
kind of new stuff it was it's really
just uh and it's and so this was
university of washington facebook
uh it came out not that long after bert
and so what they showed was that burt
was really under trained
and so basically they took even on the
same amount of data which was
which was even though i did 40 epochs on
the data if you do it for like 200
epochs you get even better results like
significantly
um so they uh so basically they trained
more
more ebooks on the same data and they
also showed that more data helps which
is also not super surprising
and they did improve masking and
pre-training using a couple of a couple
of tweaks to that and they
and they were able to get uh
state-of-the-art results which is cool
uh and so yeah but that was a pretty
straightforward paper
so the next one is xlnet which was done
by uh
some interns in cmu when they were at
google brain and so this actually had
some some really
cool changes so
one of them was they used this
transformer xl which was actually the
precursor done by the same people
that uh where they were just doing links
only tests did a pre-training
but the big one of the big innovations
of transformer xl
is this idea of relative position
embeddings and so
with absolute position embeddings the
problem is that
every word gets like this is word
for this is word five this is word six
and so they are embedding so they do
generalize
but in in practice there's a quadratic
number of relationships like how does
word 83 relate to word 76 right that's
that's that's like and once you get
bigger like 500 a thousand
now you have a thousand squared total
relationships like you have to say how
does word 997 relate to whatever
right and so that's obviously not
optimal once you get to a large size
and so with with
uh relative vision embeddings you
basically can
say how much does
dog attend to hot and how much should
the word dog attend to the previous word
and then you get and these are
non-linear for or so these are linear at
first
but then you combine them and then you
get a non-linear uh
contextual orientation then you do this
in many many layers and this ends up
being
so then you say how does this contextual
organization of dodge how much do that
detect the previous word
and then you kind of get can build up
and so this generalizes much better for
long sequences
so that's a cool uh innovation and then
the other one
which is specific to pre-training and
not just the model itself
is this idea of permutation language
modeling so this is a little bit hard to
explain
i think the paper uh explained it very
formally i guess
and so um but basically
there's a trick where so in a left to
right language model every word
done predicting is is based on the word
the left right
but imagine that instead of instead of
predicting all every word you can
basically take any permutation so it's
like i'm going to predict
the first word then i'm going to pick
the third word then the second word then
the fourth word
and so um that's a totally valid way and
you still get the welfare and
probability distribution because it's
still predicting one word at a time
given some permutation of the input and
with transformers and with attention you
can actually do this very efficiently
just by masking out your attention
probabilities and so
every single sentence you have you can
kind of sample a single permutation
of this and you can uh now
now you can effectively train a
bi-directional model because this word
it won't be conditioned on every still
on average every word will only be
conditioned in half the words
but this word will be conditioned on you
know
all these words to the left and all
these words to the right maybe it'll be
missing these words but that's fine
and so you get much better sample
efficiency so i thought this was a
really clever idea
uh and so and this was kind of like the
main innovation of xlnet
and so um yeah they basically get better
sample efficiency because
they're able to uh to do this random
permutation and kind of take advantage
of this so this wouldn't work with lftms
because
uh because of this ordering but because
the way that masking is done in
transformers it's just um
it's just a it's just a mask on the
attention so it actually ends up working
very well
and so they also got
so yeah the numbers compared to roberta
they actually ended up being pretty
similar
um but
a lot of these things are hard to
compare because people change the data
set and change the
change the size of the model so it's
hard to compare apples to apples but
these two techniques ended up being
pretty similar but i think you know
exonet had more innovations in terms of
uh
technique um so albert it's called
a light bert for uh self-supervised
learning
and so this also had a couple of cool
innovations
and so the idea here is really massive
parameter sharing
with the idea being that if you share
parameters you're not gonna get a better
language model but you're gonna get
better
sample efficiency you're gonna get less
overfitting when you fine tune right
because if you have
a billion parameters and you fine tune
them on a 300 on a data set with like a
thousand
labeled examples you're still going to
overfit very quickly right but if you if
you have
a much smaller number of parameters
you're going to get less overfitting so
we get a similar powerful model with
fewer parameters
you're going to get less overfitting and
so they
uh so the two major innovations were so
instead of using a word
because the wording table is big right
because it's the size of your of your
vocabulary the number of
uh word pieces times the hidden size and
so it's going to be much bigger than
hidden
the hidden layer so first thing is that
they used a factorized embedding table
so if they had a hidden size of a
thousand they only
use like 128 dimensional input embedding
and then they projected that to a
thousand
using uh using a matrix and so
instead of having 1024 by a hundred
thousand they would have 128 by 100 000
plus 1024
times 128 and you multiply these
together and multiply the two matrices
together and then effectively you have a
10 24 by a hundred thousand
embedding matrix um but you have much
fewer parameters but you're doing
parameter tying well not really this
isn't a problem but you're doing
parameter reduction
in a clever way the other one is
cross-layer parameter sharing so this is
similar as a simple and it was also it
was been done in previous papers
especially um universal transformer
and the idea is that you run a bunch of
transformer layers but
all let's say if you have 12 layers all
12 layers just share the same parameters
right
and so uh that ends up so so now you can
have
a a much bigger model that has
fewer parameters than bird has and so
you get less overfitting
and so um they got state of the art
compared to
x on that and roberta but one important
thing to keep in mind is that albert is
light in terms of parameters not in
terms of speed
so for a um
for the mixed for the model that's uh
that's actually comparable to to burt
um they
they actually did slightly like this
model and this model were
about the same but this one was actually
slower so it's only when they started
making models that were much bigger in
terms of compute
than bert but doing more parameter tying
then they started getting good results
and so
the implication of this is that like uh
you can you can reduce the number of
parameters
but still um nobody's figured out how to
reduce the amount of pre-training
compute that required
which is you know kind of unfortunate so
the next one is t5 which is uh
exploring the limits of transfer
learning with unified text detection
former so this was
a paper by google brain and other groups
in google
uh where they use just they used a lot
of compute and they and they did tons of
ablation on
uh pre-training they didn't like they
their goal wasn't to come up with some
with some
super clever new pre-training technique
right is really just to carefully ablate
every aspect
how much does model size matter how much
is training did it matter how much does
cleanliness of data matter
like how much does the exact way that
you do the pre-training objective matter
like how doing masking like
how many spans do you mask and so they
wanted to kind of very clearly
um uh do this and they also wanted to
push the limits of size and say what
happens if we have
300 million a billion 10 billion
parameters right
and and then so they did tons and tons
of ablation
and they got state of the art and
everything and they're still sitting
there and everything
and the results though are a little bit
bleak
uh in the sense that nothing really
mattered except making the data like
like all of the ablations
it wasn't like oh you know bert did
everything perfectly it was that
it doesn't matter like you could do 20
25 you can do this fine-tuning recipe
this functioning recipe
it's like all that really matters is
making the model bigger and trading in
more data
and clean data uh and so um
yeah it's a little bit of a of a bleak
paper if you
are hoping that there is exists some
pre-training
uh technique which is super
computationally efficient and also can
get you know very impressive results
which i'm not saying there isn't but
like most of this evidence uh
points it out so so the one kind of um
newest paper that is maybe the most
positive in this direction
is this uh paper called elektra uh
and so uh and so this is done by uh
kev clark from here and uh and google
brain and so
yeah and this one it's a pretty clever
idea so basically their idea is
instead of training instead of training
to generate the output
you just train it as a as a
discriminator and so
you have a local language model you do
some masking you have a local language
model which replaces it
and then you try to discriminate whether
it's the original one or not and so the
idea here is that
you are um doing a much
you're you're you're getting better
sample efficiency for pre-training
because you're predicting every uh
every word which is actually i mean i
don't know exactly why it would be that
different from from from because burt
still uh
in terms of because you don't replace
with er with the mask with every word
you also randomly corrupt it but but
the the bigger the biggest difference is
that um
is that these are kind of contextually
replaced so i convert when i did
random masking and replace with a random
word it was truly a random word so most
of the time it's completely trivial to
tell that this was not the right word
you didn't necessarily know which word
should be replaced
but in this case they actually used a
intentionally weak but still non-trivial
language model to predict which word so
like this locally makes sense the chef
ate the meal
but it doesn't make any sense like a
very strong model would not predict this
right so
that's the idea that you use a weak
model to to to do the substitution to
use when you train a strong model to
do this so these results are
i know this is a big table but these
results are they're certainly
positive with regard to uh previous
results in terms of compute versus
um so like for if
we compare this row so uh which is
one tenth of the compute of bert large
to bert base which is also one tenth
computer but large
it certainly does a lot better than burp
base um
but when they uh
if you but in terms of state of the art
um
when they do you know the same amount of
uh compute as their bert large
which is this one or compared to other
state-of-the-art models they're not
in order to get state-of-the-art or to
get similar to say they are they
basically need to do as much compute as
state of the art so like four four four
x five point four x
so i mean at scale down values they were
able to do better but this is a still a
pretty big gap like four points
um so it's it's positive but it's not
it's certainly not like
the silver bullet in terms of uh
showing that uh we can you know
pre-train models much better for
for cheaper so but so the last thing i
want to talk about is um
how we actually serve these models right
because you know i've said that like
they're incredibly expensive to train
and nobody
has been able to figure out how to make
that faster but you know they're being
used all over the place right so like
uh you know there's news stories google
has improved 10 of
searches by language are sending say
hello to bert and then brings says it's
been applying since april
so and so this this is live in google
search and bing search and so these are
like really low anc services right that
have like a few milliseconds of
of latency and they serve you know
billions of queries a day
so how how are they doing this is it
just like
uh that you know google and microsoft
are spending billions of dollars on
hardware what they are but not not just
for this right
and so like uh like it would
it would it would cost billions of
dollars just to serve this if you would
actually be serving bert
but we're serving uh not instead of
we're using we're using model
distillation right so this has been
around for a while
um so it's called distillation or model
compression
uh one one of the first papers was this
model compression paper
um that was that was done for
uh i forget exactly what task but then
and then hinton's paper distilling
knowledge and neural networks is a more
well-known version of
not versions but a more well-known uh uh
paper on
on distillation but in reality the one
the version that
that we use at google in the version
that most people use when they say model
distillation for
uh pre-trained language models it's a um
it's a very simple technique but but
it's easy to misinterpret what
what we mean so what we do is we
pre-train
we train the state-of-the-art model
whichever ones we can most afford to
train
right because of course we can just make
it bigger but we set some budget of you
know we want to train it for a day on
some number of tpus
and then we fine tune it right so we get
a model that's the maximum accuracy and
that's our teacher model this is
expensive
then we have a large amount of unlabeled
input which is typically for for most
industry applications you have unlabeled
input because you have you know in
search you have
this is what they use a search for this
is what they clicked on that's how it
searches they're trained
uh and so you can then just take these
and
you um and then you just label your
examples with them
so you can get billions of these if you
actually run a real service
and then you so then you then you run
these
you know query answer pairs through your
teacher
and you get a pseudo label and just
train a much smaller model
much meaning like 50 times 100 times
smaller to
predict your student your teacher
outputs and so and you can generally do
this for most
techniques i mean for most tasks you can
do this
uh pretty easily and get a huge 50 to
100x
compression with no degradation but the
important thing to realize that we're
not compressing the pre-trained model
itself
we haven't really had any luck doing
that so like you can't actually just
take
bert and then compress it to a smaller
model which you can then fine-tune for
all these other tasks it's only
after you've chosen the task and after
you find it tune it for this task
that you that we were able to do it um
so
to show some specific results so let's
say we have let's say we have a
large teacher this is an amazon book
reviews course this is a paper that
i've got to cite it but this is a paper
that my group uh published
julia turk uh wrote and so
um this has fifty thousand labeled
examples and eight million
uh unlabeled examples so you you fine
tune on you pre-train vert large
normal you take the protein but large
you uh you fine-tune it on these
50 000 examples you get this 88 accuracy
right
then uh and so
but then now let's say instead of using
bert large you used a much smaller
version so this one's
a quarter of the size this one's you
know a sixteenth the size whatever this
one's about a hundredth of the size
right so this this row that's a
hundredth of size if you were to just
train it
if you were to pre-train this on the
same wikipedia bookstore just like burt
and then fine tune it you would get 82
percent accuracy
which is you know a lot worse 60 60 like
six six absolute worse which is quite a
big drop right
but then if you were to take this 88
teacher label these eight million
examples which are of course held out
this is test
this is test accuracy um and then
uh and then train this classification
model
which says this is a good about review
on these eight million examples
you can take this model that's a hundred
times smaller and get the same accuracy
as a teacher right you get the same
accuracy so that's really the uh the
cool thing about distillation
is that you can get models that are much
smaller but you still need to train the
big model in the first place so it
doesn't help the training cost it just
helps it's actually more expensive
because then you need to use this big
model to label
millions or billions of examples so it
ends up being more expensive than just
trading birth but but you can actually
serve this model
at inference time for a tiny cost so
the question is why does distillation
work so well um
so the big hypothesis is that language
modeling is kind of the ultimate nlp
task
right a perfect language model is also a
perfect question answering system
a perfect entailment system sentiment
analysis co-reference etc right because
in order to be able to do these things
you kind of have to be able you could
construct it as a language model
so when you're training a massive
language model you are
learning many millions of latent
features which can which are effectively
the same features that you need for any
other task
and so when you're doing a simpler a
fine tuning of a more specific task
what's the fine tuning is basically
taking these label these latent features
which your system happened to learn
some encoded somewhere in your weights
and you are it's kind of just tweaking
these which is why i can do it with a
single
pass over the fine tuning data and so
but once you've figured out which parts
are important
then there exists a hypothetically much
smaller model size which can still
get the same representation the same
generalization right so then you label
a bunch of examples with this fine-tuned
model and now you can learn a model that
can really hone in on just these
features that are important and so
it can it can take you know it'll it can
train a model that's 100
the size and
just honing on these features if you
have a lot of pseudo-label data
and and that's why it works and so the
evidence really is that
it just doesn't work to do
self-distillation right and so it must
be that
it's really just learning a subset of
the features for most of these tasks
um and so basically every task but
language modeling we've been able to get
distillation to work for so this
includes tasks that seem like really
hard like
question answering and search um so that
that does imply that
that language modeling itself and
predicting and which is basically
language generation also because that's
just a form of language modeling
uh is fundamentally harder than language
understanding
which is not uh super hard to
buy or at least maybe it's not
fundamentally harder but given the state
of the art
state-of-the-art models for language
understanding are fundamentally
simpler than what they do right so
presumably just doing kind of pattern
recognition
than models that are generating language
and so that's kind of why all of these
classification models can can kind of be
distilled so well um
so basically in conclusion uh the
pre-trained models work really well
they're very expensive we know how to
um kind of solve this for inference time
and we can do fast inference
but it is still unsolved uh
how to make these fast uh at training
time and moreover uh
it seems like a lot of the details about
algorithmic improvements for for making
the training more efficient
um don't seem to have a ton of benefit
in terms of at least getting
state-of-the-art results
and seems like a lot of choices don't
really matter that much and it's really
just about
you know a couple of like like compared
to just the kind of the simple
masculine bass line it's it's pretty
hard to beat that in in an apple's
established comparison
um so yeah it's a little bit uh
i mean it's a little bit unfortunate for
for from a research perspective it's
definitely good from a uh
from people who who want to build nlp
systems and who want to
especially domain specific nlp systems
like people who want to you know adapt
to a medical domain
or people where you only have a tiny
amount of data or people who want to do
startups or they want to you know build
an actual product and they only have
timing on data so it's definitely good
from that particular but
certainly i think uh from the
perspective of sometimes you know
uh uh research like as i was saying the
goal of research is to kind of like
research yourself out of a job
then it is kind of uh you know it's a
little unfortunate from that perspective
um but you know i still think that
there's there's there's a possibility
that there's going to be
a breakthrough that kind of shows how to
do computational efficiency
um without it can kind of show
compelling results that you don't need
you know such an absurdly large model or
actually besides the models matter you
don't need to make sure the expensive
model
uh to to do well um maybe it'll come
from sparsity right or something like
that where
you actually do have a really large
model just it's just sparsely activated
in some using some efficiency tricks or
whatever